bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france heures pourquoi vous
soutenez ce mouvement ces manifestations
alors on soutient pas forcément ce
mouvement attention moi je ne suis pas
forcément pour ou contre le pass and i
ter moi ce que ce que je dénonce en tant
que président de l'association des
théâtres il en région qui représente 80
théâtre en région c'est depuis cette
annonce c'est le les annulations et la
vague d'annulations que l'on à la vague
de nombreuses innovations que l'on a
dans nos lieux c'est ça la difficulté
pour nous et l'urgence absolue pour nous
où on l'a vu c'est très politisée et moi
je ne suis pas je fais pas de la
politique moi je suis chef d'entreprise
elle et tous les directeurs de théâtre
en france font pas de la politique nous
donne au théâtre on accepte tout le
monde les ceux qui sont pour le vaccin
ceux qui sont contre le vaccin pour le
pass sanitaire contre le pass annie
terre les blancs les noirs les hétéros
les homos enfin un théâtre c'est un lieu
de rencontre c'est un cetain comment
dire un lien social entre toutes ces
populations moi ce que je désole ce qui
me désole le plus c'est aujourd'hui on
sait par tout le monde mais vraiment
nous ce qu'on demande au gouvernement
c'est d'être très attentif à nos lieux
et à y aller aux conséquences de la mise
en place de ce pass à lithaire d'abord
comment le met en place aussi vite on
n'a pas les outils on n'a pas les
ressources humaines moi je ne suis pas
policier donc je ne vais pas contrôler
et je ne suis pas habilité à contrôler
les identités
donc c'est toutes ces dérives là que
l'on ne l'ont que l'on sur lequel on
allait en fait et surtout sur les aides
comment on va remplacer tous ces gens
qui ne vont pas venir dans nos lieux
c'est vraiment le cri d'alarmé de
non-lieu c'est ça c'est plus sur les
aides encore et encore vous savez il ya
un an et demi quand le candidat
commencer on n'avait pas besoin des noms
ne connaissait pas le gouvernement il ne
nous connaissait pas on était des chefs
d'entreprise classique et on vendait des
places de théâtre de l'émotion et du
rire aux gens aujourd'hui on est obligé
d'aller demander des aides parce qu'on a
plus personne dans le théâtre c'est
vraiment ça qui nous inquiète
justement à ce que vous avez eu des
directives un haut niveau du
gouvernement je parle par exemple de la
logistique est ce que ce sera à vous
vous le disiez à l'instant vous n'êtes
pas policiers parce que ce sera à vous
de contrôler à l'entrée du théâtre si
les gens possèdent un passani terre bien
sûr malheureusement c'est à nous de le
faire et on doit contrôler en fait on
nous a dit qu'il fallait qu'on se calme
l'epasa dieterle sympa sanitaire vous
avez
feuille de papier ou une application on
se cale on a un nom un prénom qui
s'affiche il faut qu'on vérifie si à
côté il ya une carte d'identité un pass
navigo une carte vitale quelque chose
qui prouve que sa personne convient de
scan est aussi la personne qui porte ce
pas sanitaires mais si vous voulez aller
au théâtre et que vous avez le passé ni
terre de votre ami avec la carte
d'identité de votre ami c'est pas à moi
de le faire
vous rentrerez quand même parce que les
deux documents auront le même prénom et
le même nom en cas de contrôle parce
qu'il y aura des contrôles on nous l'a
dit et bien vous serez responsable d'une
fausse identité ou je ne sais pas quoi
d'ailleurs parce que figurez-vous que
lorsqu'on a eu une réunion jeudi avec le
ministère il y avait plein de questions
que l'on a posé qui n'avait aucune
réponse mais pourquoi parce que tout
simplement les décrets sont pas passés
les lois ne sont pas cotées donc tout ça
n'est qu'une grosse fumisterie et une
grosse communication
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de loi il n'y a
pas de décret l'assemblée n'a pas encore
donné son accord donc on est on est en
train de se battre encore contre des
choses qui n'existent pas
malheureusement et je ne le regrette pas
où je sais pas malheureusement c'est les
chiffres sont là il ya 4 millions de
personnes qui ont voulu se faire
vacciner après les annonces des manuels
macro et aujourd'hui il ya vingt ou
trente mille personnes dans les rues si
c'est l inverse peut-être qu'il adresse
et mesure mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
assez de monde dans les rues pour
contrer toute la vague de vaccination
qu'il ya eu de l'autre côté
alors on pourrait aller encore plus dans
les tie ins et la personne qui va au
théâtre n'a pas de passé ni terme et a
déjà acheté son billet et donc elle ne
veut pas rentrer est ce que c'est à vous
de la rembourser ou est ce que l'état a
prévu des aides mais n'ont pour
l'instant c'est à nous de la rembourser
bien évidemment alors c'est la
rembourser oui et non c'est à dire que
l'on va le faire parce qu'on adore nos
clients mais dans l'absolu vu que le
client maintenant c'est qu'ils font un
pas sanitaire s'ils achètent un billet
cnat pa tini terre ou pas de test parce
qu'on est obligés d'être vaccinés on
peut aussi faire un test de moins de 48
heures est bien normal man 2 ne devrait
pas avoir l'obligation de rembourser
mais on va le faire parce que vous
rendez bien compte que si un client
vient ou essayent de venir et on le
refuse qu'on le reverra plus c'est
toutes ces applications la con mais
qu'on met en lumière et c'est ça le
danger pour nos entreprises mais je
parle de nous
et on pourrait parler des bars des
restaurants et de toutes ces professions
à qui on impose ça et nous c'est la
vraie vie donc c'est nous qu'avant le
client en face vous avez eu des retours
de vos collègues
oui bien sûr on a fait une ag
aujourd'hui donc bien sûr que dans nos
lieux il ya des gens qui sont pour eux à
sanitaire il ya des gens qui sont contre
le pass annie terre c'est ce que je vous
ai expliqué au début nous c'est ont
regroupé énormément de gens donc on peut
pas avoir tous les mêmes envies on va
pas toujours de la même manière on a nos
idées politiques chacun mais en tout cas
le le discours général c'est ça c'est
d'abord on n'est pas policier donc on a
très peur des réactions des gens qui va
contrôler ces gens là et comment on va
gérer les situations un peu d'énervement
par exemple parce qu'on le voit là dans
la rue il ya des situations d'énervement
donc ça on n'a pas les moyens et qui
surtout qui va nous aider financièrement
pour contrer et pour combler tous ce
manque à gagner
loïc bonnet merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
vous êtes président de l'association des
théâtres privés en région merci à vous